a day to celebrate past russian
successes with old allies president
vladimir putin arrived at the vostochny
cosmodrome in russia's far east with
bella russian president alexander
lukashenko
to mark 61 years since one of the
biggest achievements in russia's history
april 12 1961 russian cosmonaut yuri
gagarin became the first man in space a
clearly happy memory for the president
who says he still remembers that day as
a nine-year-old boy but the ongoing
conflict with ukraine is still at the
top of the agenda for president putin
unfortunately ukraine was created as
some kind of launch pad for aggression
against russia and the offshoots of
nationalism were totally cherished this
new generation of ukrainian nationalists
are especially clashing with russia you
see how nazi ideology became a fact of
life in ukraine it was unavoidable we
are taking steps to provide security for
russia we didn't have any other choice
we did the right thing and i have no
doubt that our aims will be achieved
russia's so-called special military
operation is now in its second phase
which officials say will focus on the
dambass region of ukraine vladimir putin
also praised russian troops for what he
calls efficiently courageously and
competently carrying out their operation
that operation was a topic of
discussions between the russian
president and his bella russian
counterpart belarus has hosted russian
troops since earlier this year
and the kiev government accused minsk of
allowing their borders to be used by
russian troops to enter ukraine
despite the criticism from the west
president lukashenko's support for
vladimir putin continues to be
unwavering
prior to their meeting lukashenko vowed
belarus will always be by russia's side
the two presidents emerged from their
discussions with renewed determination
to consolidate their unity which will
include closer military ties
we discussed in detail important issues
including political diplomatic economic
and of course military and defense our
modern history hasn't seen yet such
dangerous and complicated moments in our
relationship with the west putin also
praised lukashenko's role in starting
the negotiations between moscow and kiev
which are still ongoing but the russian
president admitted that they have now
reached a deadlock those talks between
russian and ukrainian officials began
just a few days after russia's military
operation but there were never any high
hopes that they would bring an end to
the fighting anytime soon
now vladimir putin has confirmed what
many feared that this conflict will only
end once russia achieves its objectives
regardless of how long it takes and at
what cost
dorso jabari al jazeera moscow